for the past 40 plus years liberals
successfully purged almost all
conservatives from academia the
entertainment industry and journalism
and one by one those sectors ultimately
fell victim to oppressive groupthink
which had a terrible effect on their
work product and their credibility
dissent was not tolerated and the
punishment for deviating from the
sentiment du jour grew harsher over time
now even liberals aren't immune who can
forget when comedian Kevin Hart lost his
Oscars gig a few years back or how
colleges have routinely reacted to
conservatives speakers on campus
[Music]
yeah all right
[Music]
[Applause]
or how columnist even those who are pro
gay marriage and dislike Trump lose
their positions when they say something
shockingly science-based
meanwhile shut out from jobs affecting
the culture traditionalists and just
fair minded people went into law and may
be in business and during Republican
administrations some of them worked in
government I'm fiscally conservative but
a social liberal became the acceptable
way for mainstream types to describe
their cultural beliefs but as we've been
reminded over these last 14 days or so
the culture is where the battle for our
future will be won or lost
so when you see 20-somethings
carrying signs that spell America with a
KKK yelling in the faces of police
officers or National Guardsmen remember
that they learn this behavior from
either their radical parents or their
progressive teachers or maybe activists
celebrities all validated along the way
by a fawning press corps what we're
witnessing is a relentless propaganda
war against the old teachings about
America it's an effort to smear our
history and our patriotic spirit for
decades conservatives from Phyllis
Schlafly and they tried to trash her
recently to build Bennett warned about
the poisonous effects of the cultural
monopolies but they were largely ignored
after the death of true liberals like
Christopher Hitchens I'm hard-pressed to
name any prominent liberal who would
openly oppose today's cancel culture
this was Hitchens in 2006 it's not just
the right of the person who speaks to be
heard it is the right of everyone in the
audience to listen and to hear and every
time you silence somebody you make
yourself a prisoner
your own action because you deny
yourself the right to hear something we
miss him a few decades back many
Republicans and even some liberals
dismiss things like critical feminist
theory and critical race theory at our
universities as kind of harmless musings
of a radical fringe well today those
theories are mainstream because good
academics and administrators were just
too weak or too afraid to push back so
now you really can't read Huckleberry
Finn without hearing that Mark Twain was
just a hopeless racist or even Macbeth
without being lectured about
Shakespeare's misogyny guilt is marketed
and foisted on liberals and
conservatives alike by the new
Bolsheviks that's what I'm calling them
from now on
that protesters these are the new
Bolsheviks and they're eager to wipe
away everything that came before them
and they want to force everyone else to
beg for forgiveness now why would anyone
be surprised that a statue of
Christopher Columbus was pulled down
instead of blaze in Richmond last night
with another in st. Paul being
vandalized tonight or that entire city
blocks in Seattle now look like
Mogadishu circa what 1991-92 governors
and mayors even corporate CEOs
are positively panic they have a case of
the vapors by what's been happening in
the streets and they're desperate
falling all over themselves to placate
or even work with these new
revolutionaries GOP lawmakers violate
their own principle of federalism but
considering plans to create a national
database to track state and local police
officers hvo removes gone with the wind
from its offerings Lego takes the very
brave move of ceasing marketing little
plastic police figures none of this will
work giving into threats always leads to
more threats these weak efforts at
pandering are only going to encourage
the kind of nonsense we're seeing
tonight and poor
Smith Virginia were going to get to that
in a minute more controls less freedom
that's what's coming now back in January
of 2019 I told you to watch out
because New York congressman Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez was not someone to be
dismissed but that in fact she would
soon become the thought leader of the
Democrat Party people were surprised
when I said that well I'm gonna Pat
myself on the back but I was right and
her partner in neo Marxism Ilan Omar has
also become a folk hero what are you
willing to sacrifice to make sure that
overfunded police departments are
defunded we need to completely dismantle
the Minneapolis Police Department now it
sure didn't take long for their
progressive wish list to dominate the
national conversation did it
and so now Pelosi and Schumer they find
themselves in this really awkward kind
of uncomfortable position they need that
really need the rage and enters the
energy of the streets to beat Trump in
November that's what they think
but with that they also get the looting
in the destruction and the ultimatums
that no sane person should ever give in
to remember the cries of those Chicago
aldermen we played you last night
my major business district
it's just shattered you lose the two
biggest eyes or so yes come back what
are we gonna do and what do we tell our
residents other than good faith people
stand up it's not going to be enough no
I want an answer I still can't get over
that they are literally crying and
begging mayor Lightfoot to help save
their burned-out neighborhoods and
Lightfoot basically told them to bleep
off same outcome in New York and LA and
st. Louis by the way well begging for
mercy from tyrants like Lightfoot or
Ralph Northam or de Blasio or or
Garcetti in LA he's too weak to be
called the tyrant but you get
point the more you beg the more they
take it doesn't work if you have a 401k
if you own a home or maybe heaven forbid
someday you want to own a home if you
want safe streets and you want police to
show up
good police of course when you need them
do not expect Joe Biden is gonna be able
to help you because if Joe Biden wins in
November the antifa BLM crowd is gonna
go through him like a hot knife through
butter whoever is really gonna be
governing the country if he ever became
president we'll just keep trying to cut
deals with the radicals we'll take down
this statue here will adopt this slogan
there until the main symbols of America
will basically just be a bunch of nasty
graffiti and charred buildings those are
going to be our monuments equal
opportunity equal treatment under the
law will be replaced with a reign of
cultural terror and retribution against
the old order
just ask the law-abiding residents of
Seattle this is what their cultural
revolution looks like
[Applause]
these are liberals are going after far
left progressive liberals all of us who
still believe in free thought free
debate who are against this campaign of
bullying and intimidation have to
support a return to peace prosperity and
public safety and president Trump you
might think he's rough around the edges
but he's the only candidate who will
stand up for the average American
against these modern-day Marxist we need
him to win but that's not enough the
Democrats who have tolerated and indeed
fomented this violence we need to teach
them a lesson so vivid that they will
finally gain the courage to take back
their party from the radicals who now
dominate it now some folks may be
uncomfortable with the idea of America
first okay but I think most oppose the
BLM and Tifa idea of America cancelled
and that's the angle